the jesus i know streaming right now on
fox nation and here's an exclusive clip
and i remember saying to people how
could i not be a christian in this
business there's so much rejection right
yes there's it's a brutal brutal
business but jesus we had we had that
the secret weapon we had the lord with
us yes
kathy lee's here to tell us maureen
kathy lee hello and good to meet you
finally and you harold nice to see you
the red hat's back huh no i just had
your back what a handsome a couple of
additions we have around here
thank you
we know what's wrong you know what's
wrong with you
yeah can i shall i share a little story
about you first before we go into
everything just for fun because i don't
want to run out of
time for the end of it there was a time
when i well greg and i were quite close
and he and his beautiful wife elena
would come to my home in greenwich
no don't tell it yeah
oh my gosh what it stopped you guys what
happened there we stood out in my garden
on like a saturday beautiful saturday
and he would start drinking my gift wine
and he would not stop drinking my gift
wine and elena would go no greg
we've got to go home got to go home and
i could not get rid of the man finally i
called my bouncer that's my son cody who
had to carry him out that day
do you even he's been thrown out of
worse places than kathy lee's house
i did lose a lot of weight but you look
very happy there
you see why you wait for the picture yes
it's a timing thing regis would have
gone ballistic if you'd seen that
all right so tell us about the jesus i
know who is the jesus you know well the
jesus i'm i know is has been well
chronicled i've written many many books
on the subject and always talked uh very
openly about my faith which is who i am
it's not jesus isn't somebody i go and
visit in a building on a weekend i don't
i'm not a proponent of religion i love
relationship with the living god
scripture says in him we live and move
and have our being that means every day
so i don't separate the secular from the
spiritual in my life and it just keeps
me grounded and real but i realize that
in this world where so many people just
get so upset that you're not just like
them you don't vote like them you don't
look like them you don't worship like
they do we've stopped learning from one
another because of it and that's the
kiss of death for any for civilization
we just start we just decide who you are
and what you are and then we just we
cancel you i'm not going to get
political because i don't but here's the
thing if i follow somebody who embodied
love and embodied forgiveness and
embodied second third fourth fifth
chances whose name is jesus then i'm not
going to cancel anybody i'm going to
give them another chance when i meet
somebody i want to love them and then i
want to continue to love them until they
no longer never i no longer recognize
that person because they've been
transformed not by my condemnation but
by my love so as a result when i go on a
movie set or or a radio show or or the
rockettes or wherever i've been all over
my crazy career i've met people and had
downtime on sets with them and we talk
we talk about who we are and what we
believe and and greg and i have talked
had a lot of talks about that
but you know before that happened and um
you know and and i love to hear from
what people have to say so there's a new
book and the new special uh is based on
is 25 different interviews with people
that many of them you'll know and many
of them are just ordinary there's no
such thing as an ordinary person but not
a well-known person and they have
profound things to say about who jesus
was who they think he is do they think
he was ever really a
true historical figure to and these are
people that are scientologists they're
sikhs they're hindus they're agnostics
and so it's a fascinating thing and i
was surprised by the success of the book
and um and then fox nation wanted me to
do something with him for the last few
years and i said i think this would make
a really interesting uh series and uh so
we we made it and it's kristin chenoweth
it's justin bieber's mother i wanted to
ask about her so what was yeah so her
name was uh patty maletti so what did
you if you can share just a little bit
about what would we learn from her
in this special i think you would learn
uh first of all how much she has grown
as a human being since she was gave
birth to to a superstar she had no idea
she was an unmarried broken
addicted had just tried to kill herself
people don't know that she had tried to
commit suicide before and she gives
birth because she just felt like it was
the right thing to do and he becomes
justin bieber so it's a child having
giving birth to a child
and um and and then she talks very
openly about how once she raised him to
love god because she had become a
christian
and then he gets into hollywood with
these gifts that he has that are just
she said he was beating drums when he
was in the womb just like but not just
wild and crazy just
like real melodic and rhythmic jump not
rhythmic drums
and she talks about how difficult it was
for her
to to have to stand back and trust that
the work she had done in her son as when
he was growing up was going to cover him
when he got into hollywood and got into
all the excess and all the embarrassment
and she said i'm still his mother i
still have to pray the bible says that
teach your children raise them up in the
way they should go when they get older
they will not depart from it so she's
just very honest and raw and real i love
her from all the people that you've
spoken with you know you mentioned jesus
as a historical figure but with all the
different religions that and and
ideologies do do people agree that he
was a historical figure or everyone that
i spoke to did everybody i spoke to
agreed with it and i like craig ferguson
i talk about being on my movie set then
came you with craig
and and and he's you know what he said
to me which is it's heartbreaking to me
i told this story in the book he said
cathy cathy you're scottish scotty why
do you love me in ricky gervais why do
you love us we're not good guys i said
you are good guys why do you say that he
said why don't we don't believe like you
do we don't vote like we're just so
different from you why do you love us
and i said well first of all you're made
in the image of god and god loves his
creatures his creation and and i love
god so i love who he loves so you're
sort of guilty by association
and and he said and plus you're just
wonderful you're a wonderful human being
he said something to me that just broke
my heart he said no person of faith has
ever told me or ricky that god loves us
that we that we love you're the
it's not that god i said that wrong
actually he said no nobody's ever told
us that that they love us from that
world and i said well i then i think
you've never really met a person of
faith because somebody that truly loves
god loves jesus and believes that he is
god incarnate and taught us to love not
to condemn
would wouldn't do that we just you don't
you're amazing
thank you we love you crazy
how much and we love you so much because
you showed an embarrassing picture of
greg well yeah but
he wasn't embarrassed then because he'd
already seen it all right so the special
i've got naked ones on them all right
now let's let's not go to commercial
then all right the special fox nation
right now the jesus i know the hottest
thing on fox nation besides the hunter
laptop special but this thing is good
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else